[Musik]
die wunderwelt von bruno weber kaum
vorstellbar dass man hier mitten in der
schweiz ist fast 50 jahre lang hat der
künstler einen ort geschaffen der seiner
vorstellungskraft entsprungen ist
fantasie kreaturen und fabelwesen gibt
es hier an allen ecken mit seiner frau
maria anna weber lebte hier bis zu
seinem tod 2011 sie weiß was ihn zu
dieser verrückten anlage inspiriert hat
märchen und mythen hatten ganz sicher
einen einfluss
wir lassen uns auch immer wieder vor vor
dem einschlafen beliebte vertraute orte
vor allem gotische kathedralen hat immer
wieder dann aus dem eigenen geschäft es
gibt mappen voll ideen die er gern noch
ausgeführt hätte bruno weber war maler
architekt und bildhauer zugleich erlebte
in und mit seiner kunst seine frau maria
anna weber hat all die jahre an seinem
werk mitgearbeitet
sie hat betonfiguren gegossen was sie
heute noch mit ihrem enkel macht mosaike
gelegt und zeigt auch immer noch park
und wohnhaus den besuchern
ich zeige euch haus kommt mit rein
[Musik]
ja ich möchte euch hier verbaut garten
zeigen den bruno das symbolisch was raum
dargestellt hat ihr seht hier die tiere
des waldes quasi umgesetzt
die sträucher das feuer das die sich in
welt
macht
und da sieht man die skulptur die das
menschliche und tierische vereinbart
gleichzeitig der geschirrschrank ist
gegessen wird hier entweder am tisch
grill oder am transparenten
schmetterlings tisch mit geflügelten
stören
hier gibt es überall wege und durchgänge
zum entdecken
[Musik]
im ersten stock das familien badezimmer
wie eine tropfsteinhöhle mit bunten
edelsteinen die riesige badewanne war
vor allem ein großer spaß für die
zwillingstöchter der webers das
schlafzimmer gleich nebenan fröhlich und
positiv durch die sonne durch das tiefe
liga auf ein stockwerk weiter oben
wartet die nächste überraschung hier
kommt man in das sternen zimmer ein ganz
besonderer rückzugsort auf achteckigen
grundriss mit direktem blick in den
himmel
[Musik]
bruno hatte hier seinen tisch stuhl
zeichnete macht einfach immer so dass er
ungestört war
wenn bis hier auf durften die besucher
nicht die frauen wurde auch benutzt für
feste einen traum
es war der raum für silvester
[Musik]
im park von bruno weber dreht sich alles
um grenzenlose phantasie und
vorstellungskraft und am ende ist es
fast sicher zu sehen dass die normale
schweizer welt mit ihren fabriken und
schornsteinen direkt vor der haustür
liegt